foreign
Mansfield Ohio what's up Melissa
hi Dr John thanks for taking the call of
course thanks for calling what's
happening how can I help
I'm wondering at what point do I
distance my self and my children away
from my parents or keep fighting for the
relationship
that sounds heavy tell me more
so about 10 years ago
um my husband and I made the decision
that we wanted to leave the Mennonite
community and culture
and my parents didn't take it very well
and they said that
I needed to still wear a covering
to be welcome in their home
so we decided okay we can do that and we
did that for many years we tried our
best to honor that request
and then
um
lately I'm just feeling like I I'm done
I want to be accepted for who I am
and
um my sisters and I were in a prayer
study time for a while and I found out
recently that my mom wants to
not be part of it because I don't wear
uh head covering to pray
and I'm just not sure if I
have the strength to keep fighting or if
it's just time to walk away
so I'm going to say something really
hard
that you know innately in in your bones
but I'm gonna say it out loud okay okay
your parents have chosen their faith
over you
yeah
and so it's not a matter of you
continuing to fight for a relationship
it's a matter of you accepting a reality
and where it lies
and I'm not going to judge your parents
and I'm not going to judge you
you all have each made the decisions
that have brought you here
um if you feel that you can no longer
wear a head covering I applaud you from
the depths of my soul because I know
what that value costs you and our values
always cost us things
whether it's jobs or relationships or
whatever they always have a have a price
to pay
um
and in a sideways way I've I applaud
your parents they're willing to lose
their daughter
uh-huh that's that's one heck of a value
proposition that they have are
subscribing to
right yeah what gets stuck in the
crosshairs is
you're just a girl who wants her mom
and Mom is saying I'll only take you if
you if you dress right
and at the core of our guts that hurts
man I'm so sorry
yeah it does and you just want your kids
to go play with their granddad like you
have in their that picture in your head
around the fireplace
and Granddad says I'd love to but you
got to dress right
otherwise they're not welcome in my
house
right and that hurts bad doesn't it
yeah
and
exhale because I can feel it on you
exhale out
it is it just is
so there is no fight here
there's grief
yeah
and grief is not something you do with
your fist grease grief is something you
do
with your hands wide open it is yeah
yeah
and
um
I'm really sorry
because you've had this idea that if I
just keep
playing the charade or I just keep
pretending that everything's gonna be
okay and it hasn't been okay for a
decade
spray
and they've they've changed you know
they told us one thing and then they've
changed that criteria and so I know it
will but they're allowed to
yeah and you're allowed to change yours
okay they're grown-ups and so I'm not
gonna fight what was I'm not gonna fight
what I want to be
I'm gonna accept it I'm gonna have my
heart broken by it I'm gonna be grieved
by it and then I'm gonna figure out what
comes next
because because what's the alternative
there is no other alternative other than
to
continue with a charade something that
I'm not something I don't believe in and
teach my kids that your values are only
as strong as your cowardice
or and that your kids will feel that
tension leading up to the three weeks to
go visit Grandma and Granddad they're
gonna feel that awkwardness while you're
there
and only is going to get worse as you
get old don't subject them to that
yeah because they're already bringing up
questions they're already starting to
ask questions of course yeah
of course and they're like they're I
would hope you're raising kids and ask
good card questions right
yeah so they made their choice and now
you've got to make yours
and so if your mom chooses to not be a
part of your new Bible study because of
how you dress she's allowed to make that
choice
and you can tell her hey we'll continue
to set a spot for you because we'll miss
you
mm-hmm and that might be some time of
weeping that might you be you writing a
letter to her that you're never going to
send
that you put in the fireplace sometime
in January but you write the letter and
just say hey
you're my mom and you're supposed to
love me whether I've got certain clothes
on or not
mm-hmm and I miss you
and here's what you're gonna miss you're
gonna miss your daughter and you're
gonna miss your grandkids
but I've got to find people that are 5
10 15 years ahead of us me and me and my
husband that we got that can mentor us
that can be there for our kids because
y'all are choosing to not
and that's that's their choice
right
yeah
really really hate this for you I hate
this for them
I can't imagine they want to be losing
their daughter and grandkid grandkids
yeah so what comes next
let them know that we probably won't be
at their holiday get-togethers
or maybe this year
you guys just let them know hey we're
gonna do we're doing another thing this
year
leave them out of the equation
this year we're not going to travel this
year we're gonna we're doing our own um
this smaller family intimate Gathering
we wish y'all Merry Christmas
kids can FaceTime Grandma Granddad and
call it
make this about you you're making
grown-up choices
the fight's over putting my son putting
my swords and my shield down
how do we explain it to our children
uh how old are your kids
uh seven and nine
um
that's probably a little bit too young
for them to fully grasp the gravity of
things and so I would let them know that
this year y'all just made some choices
that we're gonna We're not gonna go to
Grandma and Grandad's this year
we're gonna do Christmas at home
but why why
it's just gonna be best for our family
this year
okay what are two or three things you
guys want to do
and be very certain that on Christmas
morning or whenever y'all do your time
together with your family
um
you're gonna be so sad
yeah
feel it and let your kids know I'm just
missing Grandma and Granddad
tell them I miss him this year oh why
don't we go see him hey it wasn't good
it wasn't good for us this year
okay okay at some point you will have to
say
I no longer buy into this particular
parts of this religion
and I don't believe in wearing a head
covering and Grandma and Granddad said
that either I wear a head covering or
I'm not welcome in their home
and either y'all wear head coverings
you're not welcome in their home
and I chose to follow my beliefs and my
values
and at some point you have that
conversation with them probably closer
to 11 or 12.
okay when they can fully grasp it and I
think you do it not out of spite or
hatred and your grandparents sting go to
no I mean they think this is a a an
eternal decision they're they're they're
making they wouldn't stake their
relationship with their daughter and
their grandkids if they didn't think
that right so cool I'm not gonna fault
you for it
but I don't have to participate because
I'm an adult
see what I'm saying this this is the
language of somebody who has stopped the
war
okay
okay and this is gonna by the way you've
been fighting for a decade you're gonna
have to learn a new identity you haven't
lived in peace time
correct you don't know how to live in
peace time and my guess is your mom has
been
oh geez
y'all have been fighting for a lot
longer than just 10 years is that fair
uh yeah
you don't know how to live in peace time
so I want you and your husband
um to go spend some time
mapping out what a peaceful life is
gonna look like let's build this thing
and let's try to lean into it let's just
don't wander off into the desert because
you're gonna run out of water
uh-huh
is that cool yeah
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of uh own your past change your
future for you and your I'm gonna send
you two of them both for you and your
husband to read together and y'all can
highlight your own keep by each other by
the bed
um and then you can walk through all
right in this upcoming new year what do
we do what do we do next
um after we have to own here's what has
happened here are the stories we were
born into and here's the stories we're
not curing with us anymore
um and by the way if you're listening to
this on January 2nd or after the new
year I realize that sounds pretty
strange because we record this before
actually before the Christmas holiday
and so
um
you may have already endured Christmas
holidays or are experiencing the back
half of your first year of boundaries
just know
um
as you head into 2023
the more you can own reality
the more you can give other adults in
your life the grace and opportunity to
make the choices they want to make
like the first caller you want to hit me
cool I'm out
actually that's that's a terrible
example because in no way is that cool
um you're going to jail and I'm leaving
um you want me to do something that goes
against my core religious values great
you're not welcome here or great I'm not
coming
you want me to do what it work yeah I'm
not doing that
um I wish you the best you as a business
owner are allowed to demand that of your
employees I'm going to choose to not be
one of them and I may not be able to
choose it right now but I'm going to
spend the next 18 months working three
jobs or four jobs
and getting myself in a position so I
never
ever have to take this again
I'm not gonna fight you
I'm just gonna head out
and I've created a non-anxious life that
allows me to do that
2023 is going to be the year where we
lay the swords down and the shields down
stop fighting
and we just go live our lives